[Music]  it all happened so fast we have to stop  them Batman whatever they are they're  going to regret stepping foot and Gotham  this is our big score gentlemen get the  bat fire fire  do I look like a friggin bat to you huh  [Music]  I've read rumors about a supernatural  back creature in Gotham but I assumed it  was an urban legend Ninja Turtles  we came to Gotham to stop shredder and  the Foot Clan  [Music]  man who'll help us destroy this city is  right behind this door Robin Batgirl  these inmates were the deadliest  criminals in all of Gotham let's move  it's time for this city destroy himself  take him down  we need answers you're welcome to try he  thought too fast  [Music]  we're not your enemy this is still my  city  if they're ready for a fight we bring on  a freakin fight  one no match for me  [Music]